I have a fun little story for you we
talked with the lovely Megan Markel two
years ago and asked her who her ultimate
talent crush was her girl crush and she
said you that's amazing she's so
beautiful and so talented and I'm so
very happy for her so I'm thrilled for
the opportunities that lay ahead for her
and I just I'm so happy for her cuz
marriage
rocks so welcome to the club girl her
marriage is gonna be televised you're
gonna tune in to the Royal Wedding
probably I remember when my mom woke me
up as a bitty girl to watch Princess
Diana get married so I probably will
tune in
Kerry Washington looked pretty regal
herself Thursday night at the Actors
Fund scandal series finale event she
opened up to ET about her journey as
Olivia Pope what does that mean - how
did you mention illipe repair for this
moment you know I think we were all so
filled with real emotion about it ending
that we just kind of let the script work
through us when you read that finale
script what was your initial reaction
you know at the table read of the finale
script they actually hadn't tissues all
along the people because they knew that
everyone would be crying and we were
those tissues got used talked a little
bit about the scandals sisterhood that
you've formed the relationship between
you Darby Bellamy and Katie what does
that mean to you they're my sisters they
really are my sisters I cannot tell you
how magical it's been for me at this
point in my life I've always been an
only child and now I have sisters it's
very special
what do you hope that Olivia Pope's
legacy is gonna be you broke so many
barriers with this role and we've loved
her for seven seasons
I hope our legacy is I hope that we are
remembered for being courageous and bold
and kind to each other yet ET we're not
ready to let you go how many years until
we get that scandal reunion oh I don't
know that's a Shonda Rhimes question but
ask her ask her we did and we had said
like could you ever envision a reboot
because there's no rebooting Olivia Pope
well she didn't ask me but she's in
charge so there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]